look forward in time to view alternate
futures to see all the possible outcomes
of the coming conflict how many did you
see 14 million six hundred five how many
we win
[Music]
[Music]
there's no other way
there was no other way the last words of
dr. strange before he turned to dust
which not too long before he saw over 14
million different scenarios of where him
and the Avengers fought Thanos in which
there was only one time that they
actually beat him and dr. strange saying
there was no other way at the end of the
movie confirms that this is all part of
that one scenario where they win and
that scenario included Doctor Strange
giving Thanos the time stone but he made
such a big deal about Thanos not getting
his hands on the time stone so that
leaves the question why did he end up
giving it to him well it is very
possible that he cursed it and there's
actually some pretty strong evidence to
support this real quick don't forget
about the infinity war blu-ray giveaway
if you would like to enter for your
chance to win all you have to do is be a
subscriber like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero again there does seem
to be evidence to support that dr.
strange cursed the time stone for
starters when he fought against evany MA
in New York he straight-up said he put a
spell on it and he said it was quite
unbreakable then evany MA told him he'd
take it off his corpse and dr. strange
said you'll find removing a Deadman
spell troublesome spell but quite
unbreakable and I'll take it off your
clothes
so here's the deal evany ma never undid
the spell if he did he would have gotten
the time stone and he died so he can't
exactly tell Thanos that there's a curse
on now it's arguable whether or not the
curse is on the eye of agamotto or the
time stone itself but it's actually kind
of irrelevant because dr. strange gave
Thanos the time stone without the eye of
agamotto but he still could have cursed
the time stone itself and for argument's
sake we're going to say he did and
further proof is that when Thanos
actually puts the time stone into the
Infinity Gauntlet dr. Strange's green
room spell shows up and this doesn't
actually quite make sense this doesn't
happen when he puts any of the other
stones inside the Infinity Gauntlet the
green room that shows up is not an
attribute of the time stone it's an
attribute of the mystic Artes a perfect
example would be you see dr. Strange's
orange runes all of the time and all
throughout Infinity Ward so again this
is a mystic Artes thing not a time stone
thing yet we still see the green room
pop up but more importantly we see it
when he uses the time stone to bring
vision back to life why is this so
different than him using all of the
other stones why doesn't it just light
up dr. strange uses his mystic arts to
control the time stone Thanos doesn't
use mystic arts he uses the gauntlet to
control the time stone so why is the
rune popping up I think it's because dr.
strange cursed it and whenever he uses
the time stone the curse or the spell
appears and I think that curse is what
could have destroyed the Infinity
Gauntlet after the snap this could be
dr. Strange's only way they could win
put a spell on the time stone that
destroys the Infinity Gauntlet after the
snap that way he can't use the gauntlet
to control all the stones anymore now
The Avengers have a chance and you have
to remember what dr. strange said about
the spell you'll find removing a Deadman
spell troublesome
moving a troublesome you'll only wish
human dinner well after the snap dr.
strange is dead could his death be what
activated the spell and caused the
Infinity Gauntlet to be destroyed I
think that it is very possible and I
think that infinity war actually shows a
lot of evidence pointing towards this so
let me know what you all think about
this theory do you think dr. strange put
a spell on the time stone and do you
think that spell is what broke the
Infinity Gauntlet share your thoughts
with me in the comments below and don't
forget about the giveaway if you would
like to enter for your chance to win a
copy of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray
all you have to do is be a subscriber
like this video and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you